das ist wirklich eine erstaunliche
entdeckung mehr als 4000 einzelsterne
bilden einen gewaltigen sternen strom
der in rund 300 lichtjahren entfernung
von unserem sonnensystem das zentrum der
milchstraße umkreist und das ist in
kosmischen maßstäben gesehen wirklich
unsere direkte nachbarschaft hierbei
handelt es sich also
höchstwahrscheinlich um einen der
massereichsten sterne gruppen in der
sonne näher
warum dieser gewaltige sternstrom so
lange unentdeckt blieb und welche
geheimnisse er über unseren kosmos
verraten kann klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
aufgespürt werden konnte dieser riesige
sternen strom mit hilfe von gaia einer
weltraumsonde der europäischen
weltraumorganisation esa die im dezember
2013 ins weltall gestartet war und big
data also riesige datenmengen sind hier
wie immer öfter der schlüssel zum erfolg
ein österreichisches forschungsteam hat
jetzt diese riesige datenmenge die seit
2013 angefallen ist genauer analysiert
zu untersuchen waren unter anderem die
geschwindigkeiten und das alter von
mehreren millionen sternen in der nähe
der sonnen umgebung und dabei wurde
erstaunliches zu tage gefördert dazu
einer der beteiligten forscher stephan
meingast so haben wir diese bisher
unerforschte gruppe identifiziert deren
sterne alle mit gleicher geschwindigkeit
in die gleiche richtung fliegen gleich
alt sind und die eigenschaften eines
durch gezeitenkräfte verformten
sternhaufens aufweist
das wirklich besondere an dieser
entdeckung ist dass dieser stern strom
quasi direkt an der erde vorbei fließt
das kann man umgangssprachlich
tatsächlich so formulieren denn in
kosmischen maßstäben ist die distanz der
nächsten sterne von wohl 326 lichtjahren
wirklich ein klacks laut dem
forschungsteam ist diese entdeckung eine
premiere denn vergleichbare sterne
ströme konnten bislang nur entfernen
halo also im äußeren bereich der galaxie
aufgespürt werden dazu einer der
forscher alves dinge in der nähe unseres
heimatplaneten zu finden ist sehr
hilfreich denn so ist deren ansicht
weder zu schwach noch zu verschwommen um
analysiert zu werden der große traum
aller astronomen und die fachleute haben
in ihrer studie noch mehr details
beschrieben den nach
haben sich die sterne des stroms wohl
vor etwa einer milliarde jahre gebildet
der sternen strom selbst erstreckt sich
über hunderte lichtjahre schätzung
zufolge ist der etwa 1350 jahre lang die
sterne dieser gruppe verteilen sich also
quasi über den ganzen himmel wenn man es
von der erde aus betrachtet und genau
das erklärt auch warum der stern strom
erst jetzt entdeckt werden konnte laut
des forschungsteams aus österreich waren
einzelsterne davon nämlich bereits
bekannt doch niemand hatte den
zusammenhang zwischen ihnen bislang
erkennen können dies haben nun die
präzisen messung möglich gemacht doch
selbst kaya hat noch luft nach oben denn
selbst sie hat probleme damit
lichtschwache objekte zu erfassen so
konnten bislang nur 200 sterne des neu
entdeckten stroms identifiziert werden
doch das forschungsteam ist sich sicher
mindestens 4000 zusammenhängende sterne
bilden diesen strom dafür spricht laut
der experten und expertinnen
beispielsweise die tatsache dass sie
sich gemeinsam bewegen somit wird es
sich bei dieser entdeckung tatsächlich
um eine der massereichsten sterne
gruppen in sonnennähe handeln die nähe
zu uns sei zufällig und habe sich
einfach so ergeben unter anderem durch
die bahn unseres sonnensystems und des
sternen stroms rund um das galaxie
zentrum dennoch sind auch die
expertinnen und experten selbst über
ihre eigene entdeckung durchaus
überrascht dazu alves in der nähe
befindliche scheiben ströme zu
identifizieren ist wie das suchen nach
der sprichwörtlichen nadel im heuhaufen
astronomen haben diesen neuen strom
schon lange betrachtet da er den größten
teil des nachthimmels bedeckt aber sie
erkennen erst jetzt dass er da ist er
ist riesig umweg sich schockierend nahe
an der sonne
gigantische sternenhaufen die aussterben
verschiedenen alters und größe bestehen
sind übrigens nicht selten auch in der
milchstraße gibt es davon sehr viele
doch der größte teil davon ist noch jung
nur einige millionen jahre alt weiter
außen dagegen im halo also dieser
kugelförmigen hülle um die milchstraße
existieren auch massereiche
sternenhaufen schon seit milliarden
jahren diese wurden im laufe der zeit zu
sternen strömen auseinandergezogen
gravitationskräfte sorgen dafür übrigens
gehen wir auch davon aus dass die sonne
vor etwa viereinhalb
milliarden jahren in einem sternenhaufen
entstanden ist ihre geschwister also die
sterne dieser gruppe werden seitdem von
vielen forschungsteams weltweit gesucht
denn seitdem haben sie sich wohl über
das ganze milchstraßen system verteilt
experten und expertinnen sind jedenfalls
optimistisch dass mit hilfe von gaia
weitere faszinierende sternen ströme
entdeckt werden zudem wollen sie endlich
im detail verstehen wie galaxien
entstehen und gravitationskräfte in
diesem zusammenhang wirken die
hauptreihe der sterne einfach erklärt
dafür hier klicken anschauen und
raumzeit block der zukunft abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran